ん
いっ
いいいいいい
もし par
大江 ran
はーい
ran
あああああ
よねー
スギちゃんってやるぞと思わせないかっぴは何や協和音何点か買って兄に入ってきたん
で僕のね今ハマってるゲームをねうん
夏生のゲーム前にもうホ君の動画で紹介したんですけど今日はねそれをねまだその
ブレイブフロンティアをしたことにダンテ国ねなラージは押せなくてこれはハマれる
自社で俺やばいた秒4人取るたびにはまると rpg 系カー
マール pg っていうかワンタッチでできるゲームなんですよ
片手でそうそう本当に良て使う
ああああああああ弊社中谷握ってできるできるという気で
ブレイブフロンティアの画面ですこれからもう本当に弾てくるのは本当に1回もやった
ことないしまえば夫もないんで今日はね皆さんにもわかりやすいように
プレー日フロンティアお値段的に説明していくなんかキャラクターがあれだへ
小型ぐっ
してりゃ積んで可愛いだそうまずブレイブフロンティアっていうゲームはファンタッチ
でできる rpg ですワンタッチ
なんかねそれ難しいルールとかなくて実際にやってみた方が早いかみーたいねー
行ってみますかちゃんに僕この前よりだいぶレベルが上がって来て今ランク7発14
レベルを4年以降でクエストからよし
クリスと受けていくんですよ ipg か今いないねこういうあんまり
なんかね新しいタイプなんだけどこういういろんな地方から
馬祖以南で越冬地ファーミミっドルはイエスジャグに地方ってとこまで今に生きて
いけるよなんかすごい抑えなんというかメンター
こういう場所を選んで画面綺麗だね音楽もすごくん
所に精製用の死後車低温の凄さん
枝良い日イヤー ie
苦戦しどうやって横の西洋の死後さってところが今もう
一番難しいっていうかやら今のところでやってみて
これがネカフェのパーティーですパーティーん
55人等
5立っあと他
ソースけどで一人ですけど5人と
おい感じ5人三方五耐える
自分
オレはー抜くッ
ぶーぶーっ
ok 水況
落ち着こう本日と
5時台中
っていうわけで何ああああああバーちゃうわけじゃないしてジャ
笑ってないわ
自分が5対9と連れていけますね
笑ってるってこうやってごたえ自分のユニット連れてって
ひいったら来て混ぜ戦うところみたい
とりあえずねこういう感じで僕僕に連れて行きますよ行こうよ
う
4自分めっちゃイケ6に連れて行けばさえ
で始まります
味めっちゃこれが線と大
右側が自分
rb ジョン本当にええええ
もう最初からの戦いになってんだそういきなりこういう米入ります
で本当に簡単なんだよ
例えばどれかタップしてに1人そしたら
こっちが初めての陣痛を右側が俺の例えばいってにごたえをしてみて
そしたらのね一は小城してくる
a
明日はこれ動くんだそうそのそれじゃねすごいフミヤ的
もう自分の味方が実際に動いているから
うんすごい感動しねあとなんかこのグラフィックが
何だろうアナログというたなんか.同等で掲げトっていうん
なんか懐かしいよねそうな可愛いますねこれいくらでもできちゃう
なんかで自分のターンはたら言っての単協
これたパターン兄弟れそうね
でもいいねこういう何か動いてさー自分の仲間が選んが工夫している
ボスのようになんかこっちとかそれにポイントがあるんだポイント
ん
実はあのブーブー色咲きぐらいにょ
分ランでて
p 2 b 6を立つなんか一個一個こだわっているねその技をティアラなんても動か
ないから
6月に連れて行まあ大塚やんだな今見たと思うんだけど
扇が全員違うんだよパターンビットどうせの攻撃が同じタイミングで当たったとしたら
どうなるでしょ前科を助け徒 versa
まあなんか避けない3倍くらいになりますが3倍変わったんだけど強くなります
同じタイミングで攻撃したら威力がかかるって本当に同じタイミングに合わせたら
スパークっていうのが起こる塗ってオレにもやらせていいですよねが昆布
えっ難しいはタイミング行けば大丈夫でリズム感ある話だと思う
オロラきた機体だできて一緒できてない
なんだっつったって俺がねみんな見せてあげなんか骨盤
本当になキャラの動きを覚えるしかないんだよでもうちょっと6人全員でやろ
6人前であれば多分スパークでるんだよ
一気にはの寸
ちょっと見てても多分子がちゃんと入るか
大
これはスタースパーからスパークってこれでなんかば意外なんだ
スパークって入れたらダメージが上がる
基本的にワンタッチでこういう気だけど大事なのはそういうスパークになっていく
なるほど泥ママさんみんななんか光っ天山フェレールバーストという記事が満タンに
なってるんだよはい
こういう時は必殺技みたいなが動いますキャーキャーを治すして切っターンなんか休ま
せるとか
はぁっイカ summer heat かはあけどちらキャラいろいろ言われコナグラ
グラヴィオンやれないけど
をこの上に引っ張ったらすげー
ウォーカーカッケーこいつでね一つのことができる
しかもて動いていう
そのてごらんとねブックんで砲撃するときうん
9位だったので頼んだからこう筆記体なんです
言っていないからダメだからおっさん
んおおぉ
日焼け後ま
こいつ弱いでしょ
ハズレではないあーけど行けばよい
a
ろ過 s スプーン
オススメないっぱい歩いなってやつ何なこれはねー
できやつなんですよアリーナってなんだろうアリーナはず分のこのパーティーとはい
そのネット上の他の誰かのパーティーで本当にタイマンで戦うや大麻を
どうあれベル受けれないこれ
おじゃ90種も支援
強いでしょ c じゃん
しっかり日10日とんまいカツ
こっち殴らミョンがいるからねグラヴィオン強いよ
よしの
一人倒した
このなんとお前がたよゆ
1人もやられずに勝ちますとん
で
最低
西口南レベマ事件
そのな999せるいいよ子
じゃあ源ちまだまだじゃんまたこれから吸ってがれないこの
自分の強さはさコーテがレニーそうありなり完成も操作をしなくていいから見てるだけ
だし
って感じのブレイブフロンティアなんで
もういそろっシャッターぜ蓋をしたんだよね
ほらダウンロード地だろうと2俺もう肇社長を超える本当に越えたらなんか懲戒よ
じゃあなんか姉買ったけどねぇ
筋トレ用具
いいえ